God is with us in Phoenix Arizona
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Scott
thank you how can I help sir
well I guess I've started your program a
few months ago I'm gizelle intense about
it and I'm getting married in March of
this coming year sink right now I should
be a well thank you very much my fiancee
though carries a lot of school debt
she's carrying over $200,000 worth of
school debt and yeah what is her what is
her degree she has a doctor in physical
therapy so she's in the workplace oh
yeah she's working now
what's your hang very hard what you're
making about 85 good a year 35,000 a
year whoo and over two hundred thousand
dollars to get that Wow
yes unblockable is it she is what is the
income potential of that I don't know
hash around 90 to 95 probably worth
where she's at what you're going to do
okay I'm also a physical therapist okay
good so you're gonna have a two hundred
thousand dollar income give or take
it'll be a few about 170 that I looked
at now and you got and do you have any
death I carry about $30,000 that's it
nuts from a consolidated loan okay
before I read your books gotcha
cool otra vez no but I am I bet it's all
I care and the card debt no other than
my house which I think we're selling
judges live into a smaller area so we
can focus it more money on it gotcha
okay so I'm working what's your question
my concern is that it's going to take so
long to get out of debt now make hundred
seventy a year you live on nothing
better for LSP right now yeah you live I
mean what is her dad total I mean you
sits over 200 what is it it is three
hundred eight thousand three hundred and
eight thousand that's over three hundred
I know yeah yeah there's more there is
more than just from school oh I see what
is the rest of it uh car loan how much
you on the car
about 23,000 sell it I've said that
already
she we just started her first budget
uh-huh it so we're in the process like I
said we're in that to you now
Oh gherkins yeah we're FPU so she's on
board with doing this has listened to a
few of your podcast I've read most of
all your books are ready yeah just tap
the brakes on talking her into doing
stuff let Financial Peace University
have its effect on her that's what I've
done instead of you in city you bled let
me be the bad guy and let her come to
her own conclusions because she will I
mean she's so broke it's unbelievable
and she just got to realize it and as
soon as she does I mean we're selling
the car you like you said you moved down
in house you live on 170 a year you got
300 to clean up and you make 178 years
you live on what 50 so you throw 120 how
quick does hundred and twenty clear up
100 350 about what four years almost but
you have no life for three years and
you're going to be paying $10,000 a
month on that that's what I'm hoping to
do is throw thousands and thousand
dollars to do that but my concern is I
have about a hundred thousand dollars
worth of retirement already so my well
just I just stopped at stop adding to it
yeah yeah you guys are broke man you
can't be putting money in retirement
three hundred sixty thousand dollars in
debt three hundred forty thousand
dollars in debt yeah yeah you gotta
clean this up yeah listen if you don't
hit that this is a mammoth problem I
know if you don't hit it well everything
you've got lifestyle car sales stopping
retirement working overtime budgeting no
vacations no eating out I mean moving
down in house and you hit this thing
with you on you shoot it with every
bullet you've gotten a gun you'll be out
of debt in about three years you might
even be out faster than that but it's
gonna be about three years how old are
you I'm 45 yeah so you whatever you lose
on that think about the other side of it
you're a hundred seventy thousand are
your income you know I live on less than
you make you know how to work goals
together you're going to be able to save
and build wealth like crazy people
you'll be men
so fast your head will swim but you got
three years of hell on in front of you
true and so I mean this is a great girl
I'm sure she's worth it she is she's
awesome yeah it's um look like we all do
make some financially poor decisions was
zero
yeah with zeros and okay so stop the
funding and just hit that hard and
continue with FPU and exactly let that
do its job on her yeah yeah because I
mean let me tell her let me tell her on
the video to sell her car rather than
you going in Dave I'm baby talk to
Davison so your car that's not gonna
work you just go you're going to blow up
everything literally you know because
you're you're ahead of her on your
emotional commitment to this and the
depth of your intensity and it's going
to tell her it's going to take her a
month to catch up with you on that but
when both of you it's going to require
both of you to be as intensive and
focused as you are and that's all I'm
saying and I think that's going to you
know that's going to put you in a place
to do that so very very cool well
congratulations man on the marriage and
yeah you're doing all the right stuff
for the mess you've got couch
what a deal hey guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you enjoyed that video from the
Dave Ramsey show if you want to watch
another great video check out my video
three things you should consider rinsing
right over here or click the link in the
description below